[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that first think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a podcast where me and my
brother John answer all your questions
give you two beasts advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon hi John how are you right
I was the saddest intro I've ever heard
you know it's uh it's never a funny
comedy podcast but this particular
episode of dear Hank and John is going
to be particularly unfunny because Hanks
beloved dog lemon has just died and also
because I have just learned in the last
hour that the brilliant novelist Harper
Lee has died one of my favorite writers
and yeah so don't expect too any funny
today yeah it was always a comedy
podcast about death now it is just a
death comedy of a death podcast about
death no it's just a death podcast about
death now it's just two all death all
the time
speaking of which hang before we even
get to how we're doing which I think the
answer is universally terribly I have to
say that there is an important
correction to one of our previous
episodes and this comes from Matt who
would like to inform us that in fact
despite it being the shortest month
February is not the deadliest month at
least in the United States August and
September shared the title for the least
deadly month with the August death rate
being the lowest while September is the
lowest by total deaths February is
fourth in total deaths and third in
deaths per day so we are still in the
thick of the the death season what one
of the things you said didn't make any
sense there at the end it's its fourth
in death rate and third in deaths per
day oh no its fourth in total deaths and
third and death rate
this is too confusing for my brain right
now and all I can think is yeah this
February is a terrible time to be alive
well it is because your chances of dying
are exceptionally high yeah yeah it's
very like it it seems it seems very
unlikely to me and I would like to know
what why accept it it's cold and people
are like oh I don't know yeah had enough
of this living thing no I mean I I am
inclined to agree the best time to be
alive is probably August maybe September
depending on how you calculate it but
January and February are just
overwhelmingly the worst to give you a
little bit of context in February the
average number of deaths per day in the
United States is 7080 1 hmm in September
it's six thousand fifty one it's more
than a thousand deaths per day less Wow
that's a big difference that is not a
big difference in mine it's a big
difference in in actual numbers of
people sorry not just in numbers but in
percentage that's that's very strange
and also I'm kind of surprised by how
few people die per month well in the
United States but still that's I don't
know there's 300 million of us it's
surprising that only only 6,000 people
die and any month well what a while the
people who work for funeral homes even
do all I can tell you Hank is that I
cannot wait for August
alright well I I my favorite month of
September so I guess I guess that plays
out in the and the stats as well so we
just have to pause briefly to
commemorate the life of Harper Lee
author of tequila Mockingbird Harper Lee
who wrote there are just some kind of
men who are so busy worrying about the
next world they've never learned to live
in this one and who wrote mockingbirds
don't do one thing but make music for us
to enjoy they don't eat up people's
gardens don't nest in corn cribs they
don't do one thing but sing their hearts
out for us that's why it's a sin to kill
a mockingbird and Harper Lee who also
the single greatest line of dialogue in
American literature
miss Jean Louise stand up your father's
passin Hank she was one of my favorite
writers especially when I was a young
person and when my son was born we gave
him the middle name Atticus partly
because of the historical Atticus but
partly because of Atticus Finch the
great hero in the novel To Kill a
Mockingbird and my publisher Julie
Straus Gable
after Henry was born sent Harper Lee
some copies of my books and Miz Lee very
kindly sent one of them back a first
printing of Looking for Alaska that she
signed on the title page welcome to the
world Henry Atticus Harper Lee I feel
like that was our short poem already I
hope you don't have another one because
but I have a short poem about dog death
oh really
you found a short poem about dogs of
course I did Hank all right I'm gonna
take my headphones out you do it I like
to sort of yell when you're done okay
today's short poem is by Mary Oliver a
great lover of dogs and also a wonderful
poet this is from her book dog songs and
the title of the poem is if you are
holding this book you may not agree you
may not care but if you are holding this
book you should know that of all the
sites I love in this world and there are
plenty very near the top of the list is
this one dogs without leashes if you are
holding this book from Mary Oliver's
book dog songs I could handle that one
all right I tried there are some sadder
ones but I didn't want to make you cry
in our comedy podcast podcast John oh
man I'll tell you what it's it's weird
it's it's very my my emotions make no
sense and and they continue to surprise
me and I am learning about myself
this process and what I'm learning is I
ain't no rational being that's not what
humans are so it's yeah it's something
else and it sucks yeah I'm really sorry
she was a great dog and and it is I mean
it's just it's it's a it's a grieving
process and I think no matter what kind
of grief you experience the main one of
my main conclusions from grief is that
grief is super-weird and that if you try
to judge yourself within the process of
grief you're only going to complicate
matters because it's complex and weird
and I would argue that there aren't a
lot of wrong ways to do it but instead
you just kind of gotta let let yourself
be yourself all right well I will take
that advice John do you want to talk
about anything else before we answer a
question no maybe we should start off
with a question about death all right
that sounds like the kind of thing that
might happen here on dear Hank and John
all right so our first question of the
day comes from Abby who writes Dear John
and Hank I'm the only child of a single
parent who is dead my father and I were
extremely close and his death two years
ago was without doubt the worst thing
that's ever happened to me but it does
mean that in this terrible economy I am
a 26 year old with a low-paid artsy job
who owns a beautiful home in Inner
London outright and lives alone I
sometimes struggled to deal with other
people's reactions to this many people
are confused by my rare situation and
asked me how it happened and answering
is very awkward and I've also found that
some of my friends struggle not to sound
jealous or bitter about it as you host
the best comedy podcast about death on
the whole internet Thank You Abby I
thought you might be able to help do you
have any dubious advice for me well
answer questions that are you know
universal everyone deals with these
issues of just having this particular
situation as very it's a very it's a
very surprising and unusual circumstance
you find yourself in but I think in a
lot of ways one that that actually isn't
that unusual you know the the
ridiculousness
of capital you know of the of course
like I I believe to some extent in the
market and in the existence of capital I
understand that it needs to exist it is
very strange how so many how we all have
very different amounts of things and and
that allows you know it it makes it well
I think that the the easy way to say it
is like and you have more stuff when you
have more assets your life is easier and
you can make different choices you can
you know it is easier to do the things
that you want to do right but of course
I'm sure that also Abbie would in a
heartbeat of course you know give up her
house in inner London to have for her
relationship with her father back or to
have her father be living again and I
think that's one of the things that
makes it so complicated I mean when we
were talking earlier about how grief is
inherently complicated that's one of the
things that's complicated about it right
is that you know it's you know when you
talk about someone who's died leaving
you a legacy you know part of that
legacy is a physical house and that is a
great blessing um it doesn't make it
doesn't make the death any less horrible
it doesn't make the loss any less
horrible and you know I think that I
think the only way to deal with those
those awkward situations is to
acknowledge that they are awkward like
just to just to be like yeah I know it's
it's it is weird and I feel weird about
it too but this is this is what happened
right right and it's almost as if like
it's all a thing that we know like it's
it's a thing that we all know to say
like I'm give up a loved one for wealth
obviously like that's the thing that we
we all know but to have gone through it
is a different thing and to have learned
that lesson the hard way and so so like
there's there's also there is some
awkwardness in not just in inequality in
in material wealth but in inequality and
experience and and it can make you can
feel very
scary and very uncomfortable to talk to
someone who has lost something that you
know that is unusual to have lost at the
age that really are and and that other
people do not have that shared
experience and sadly that will get I
will get more or less common but but it
will it be less the case as you get
older yeah it will become progressively
less weird but but yeah I think that
it's I I always feel like with with
those awkward situations really the only
way to deal with it is to acknowledge
the awkwardness mm-hmm yeah you say like
okay well it was funny actually uh that
the this it's funny actually it's how I
started this sentence but the night
before we were taking lemon into the vet
to say goodbye we went to get doughnuts
because that's that's how I we were
feeling and so we went to Krispy Kreme
we were actually like out to get we were
just like picking up some food to take
home and we were like we were like oh
god were right next to Krispy Kreme so
we went to Krispy Kreme and the guy gave
us some donuts and he said so how did
you how's your night going and we were
like oh I'm not gonna answer that
question and he said he is a very nice
guy he looked at me and he was like well
I hope it goes better and I was like
thank you because like like it's it's
very strange to like his you know the
vast majority of the times people are
like how you do and you're like good but
I could not I could not bring myself to
say good and he handled it very well I
felt like in a way I handled it well but
I was also a little bit like do I look
like the kind of person who goes to
Krispy Kreme at 9 o'clock at night
because I'm having a good day I don't
think there's anything wrong I don't
think that like it's inherently
depressive to go to Krispy Kreme in the
evening I don't think there's any right
time to go to Krispy Kreme I definitely
didn't feel like well this is not a
thing that I would normally do but
it did not make me feel better it's
funny how that works I find that when I
eat poorly it makes me feel better only
while I am swallowing the food and then
within five minutes it makes me feel
much much worse all right I have another
question John if you're up for that I'm
ready
this one's from Daniel who asks dear
Hank and John remember whenever I'm
having conversations with a friend about
a problem they're having having I often
find myself suggesting solutions to the
problem instead of just listening I find
it difficult to tell the difference
between when someone wants me to suggest
solutions and when someone just wants to
be listened to what are some tips to
become a better listener I feel like I
do this a lot and John has given me
advice on this very topic and so I am
gonna shush hahaha yeah cuz God knows
you talk too much on this comedy podcast
oh yeah I mean I can only give you the
advice that my chaplaincy supervisor
gave me many years ago and that I've
tried to hold close to me ever since
which is don't just do something stand
there it is incredibly powerful to
listen and to listen empathetically and
so and so when I'm trying to listen to
someone I'm I'm always trying to to pay
close attention and then also to reflect
their feelings and experiences back to
them
so I we've talked about this in past
comedy podcast but empathetic listening
can sound a little bit stupid when
you're talking about it in the abstract
so for instance if you have a friend
who's saying you know I'm feeling really
afraid of abandonment because my
boyfriend is talking about moving to
Korea you would you you might respond by
saying it sounds like you're feeling
afraid of abandonment ideally you'll do
it in a slightly more sophisticated way
than that so the person who you're
talking to isn't like did you just
literally repeat what I said but in my
experience even if you just literally
repeat what they say it's still helpful
they'll be like yes exactly
and there's just something about having
someone else validate your
your feelings that's very powerful yeah
and I think that a lot of times people
are talking about their problems because
they need to hear them they're almost
they almost need you to be there so that
they can feel okay talking to themselves
and that's really that's really weird
but we don't feel okay talking to
ourselves a lot of the time and and also
just to help tease the feelings out
because I as I have found in the last
last few days it's very difficult to
know what you feel all the time and so
sometimes you just need to talk about it
just so that you can know and sometimes
I want to get a therapist even though
I'm pretty pretty well-adjusted person
just so I can have a person with a blank
slate and be like okay I'm just gonna
hit you with all this stuff you know you
don't know anything about me I don't
think about you let me hit you with all
this stuff
so that I can just at least like hear
what this sounds like to a person who
isn't in the middle of it right yeah no
I that's one of the big benefits of
having having a therapist I don't think
that you have to have mental problems to
go to therapy I think you know going to
a psychologist is very different from
going to a psychiatrist yeah I would I
would recommend it Hank I am I've been
in therapy since pretty consistently
since the year 2000 and my life has
gotten consistently better over those 16
years
sure correlation and causation always
the same
yeah but then again like I don't want to
mess around with anything because the
correlation is so strong yeah yeah
totally
that's but it's it's I know it's magical
thinking to some extent I have a
question Hank it's for Mallory
it is a fascinating question I do not
know if you will be able to answer it
but I find it very beautiful she writes
dear John and Hank my grandpa and I have
been in a very heated argument for about
two years he believes there is a
possibility that another planet exactly
like Earth could be in our orbit on the
opposite side of the Sun making it
impossible for us to ever see it and for
it to ever see us he saw this in an old
movie once I
no astronomer but I did take some
courses in college and I don't think
this could happen could this fictional
planet exist what a great question
well well first Mallory I have to say
I'm glad to hear you took at least some
courses in college
Mallory did not say that she took
astronomy courses but she did take some
courses there was at least one course
maybe two that were taken during college
oh man I took anthropology I took pre
calc those two I took some courses I
first I I'm glad that your grandfather
and you are able to have this spirited
debate I hope that it's that it's a it's
a pleasant one and it's it's also nice I
think when you're having a debate to
know that you're right which in this
case you are and but even but but it is
also important to recognize sometimes
you're like I know I'm right I know I'm
right I don't know why I'm right but I
know I'm right and yes Mallory is right
oh yeah I was hoping first you should
plan it it's it's unfortunate but the
reason I know I'm right is not because I
know all the reasons why I'm right it's
because I I have faith I trust that the
people who who study the universe have
thought of this thing that was
apparently in a movie a long time ago
and I've checked oh so you don't so you
don't actually know that it's impossible
I do know that it's impossible not
impossible but Mallory doesn't because
she only took some courses in college
can you explain to me why it's
impossible please we have a pretty
pretty good a pretty good grasp on the
gravitational effects that all of the
planets have on each other it is true
that the gravity that its gravitational
effects on earth would be would be
basically invisible so there there's
there's there's a bunch of different
reasons as with like lots of cool things
in in science that we that we figure out
it a bunch of different arrows all point
to the same things
mm-hmm so we know how planets form and
we know that it would be extremely
difficult for a planet to form this way
it would for for two globs to perfectly
pull all of the stuff from the planetary
accretion disk into into these opposite
points if it was even if they were even
very slightly different masses they
would eventually come together which is
what happens and why there is only one
planet in each of the orbits despite the
fact there is there's a gravitational
point at which you could put another
earth and then they would go they would
go around each other so there's that
reason there's also that you know just
sort of like the we have studied the
earth we also have have things that
sense planet like that are not on earth
so you say like yes it could be there
and we wouldn't be able to see it but we
have we have eyes and other points in
the solar system so there's lots of
different reasons why this is not the
thing that could be but it's a fun
thought experiment and also you know
like we do we do there are a number of
weird gravitational points like that and
we do utilize those two they are
gravitationally stable points and there
are asteroids in those places that are
sort of like stabili following us around
but but but not earth no big no no big
job no yeah no other no other earth
which would be amazing because it would
be really easy to get to yeah that's
what I was thinking we could get to our
secret earth
well Mallory I don't think you should
tell your grandfather about this I think
you should just continue the argument
yeah better than the arguments that are
that that I have with my my conserve my
my family members who I disagree with
things on I was like are you going to
say that we are having arguments with
our grandparents because they're all
dead but fighting it out you still
fighting it out with Danny and pop all
about about whether or not get married
they may be dead but Hank is not done
with that argument I'm kind of not
you know I will say at the end of her
life our grant the New York Times
started posting back then it was like
civil union ceremonies for LGBT couples
in in the wedding section and at the end
of her life my grandmother did say well
I think that's that's a nice thing
Wow yeah so that's a that's that's a
long journey to travel for a you know
eighty seven-year-old woman alright this
one is uh this one's from Ori who asks
dear Hank and John how do artificial
flavors such as strawberry flavor pass
as strawberry flavor when they taste
nothing like strawberries does something
trick and this something in the does
something in it trick our brains into
thinking that strawberries taste like
that or are we just used to calling it
strawberry flavor because everybody does
I have a surprisingly complicated answer
to this question John to you I have a
theory about it ok so this is my theory
sometimes when I am drinking an ice cold
refreshing I don't understand why they
continue to refuse to sponsor me diet
dr. pepper I will take a sip of that
diet dr. pepper and I will enjoy it
greatly for a moment until I realized
that it is in fact Diet Mountain Dew mmm
but my brain is so heavily expecting the
flavor that it knows to be diet dr.
pepper that my brain initially is like
that's some good doctor wait wait that
isn't diet dr. pepper at all mmm hmm hmm
so that's my theory is that you are
essentially tricking your brain with
with the color and then you're also
tricking your brain with the sweetness
yeah you're tricking your brain with
with a bunch of things and I think that
absolutely does happen and I also for me
it is a guess it is not it's not
something that that I know anything
about but I do know some things about
flavor chemistry because it is something
that I studied some when I was in
college I took some courses and and and
remarkably they
so so when we first were isolating all
of these artificial flavors which are
the things that we use in candy almost
exclusively we pulled out these all
these flavor compounds that have very
strong smells and they smell very good
to us and so we pulled them all out and
a lot of them tasted like ah this tastes
like a thing well do use it as the thing
a lot of them didn't taste like anything
though they just tasted good so it was a
flavor that we liked but it was it was
one of you know a dozen different
compounds that was in a strawberry or in
a watermelon or in a blueberry or
something so it was it was one of many
compounds and it was just part of the
subtlety of the flavor but when we
concentrated it and stuck it with some
citric acid and some sugar which is the
stuff that makes it was like the primary
flavor components of sugar of course are
like the actual tastes of sweetness and
sourness and then you have these smells
that go along with it to enhance that
are enhanced by those things you get all
of these chemicals that taste good but
don't taste like anything so we had them
they're inexpensive to synthesize and we
like them and they but like they're just
chemicals so like they're named by the
international union of pure and applied
chemistry they're not named by you know
the long history of people naming things
being like that that berry grows in
straw so let's call it a strawberry or
whatever so like that they didn't want
to call it like ethyl methyl phenyl
glass-eyed flavored candy so they called
it strawberry flavored candy today's
podcast is brought to you by ethyl
methyl glycerol eye candy what is it
called I don't even think I said it
right I thought methyl phenyl glycinate
today's podcast today's focus is brought
to you by ethyl methyl gristle sidled
eight delicious it doesn't taste like
strawberries but you're gonna like it
and we're gonna make it red you're gonna
love it yeah all right we're doing this
at the today's today's podcast is
brought to you by
many sad things too many sad things
there's a lot of them and just let them
let them pile on top of you until you
can no longer function or or even move
and of course today's podcast is brought
to you by delicious refreshing diet dr.
pepper
diet dr. pepper okay not sponsoring me
since 2007's podcast has additionally
brought to you by meloria the the the
actual planet malaria which is found
just behind the sun in the exact same
position as the earth but not by anyone
because it's hiding there and has been
and will always be hiding there just an
opportunity for us to consider what
could possibly be if the earth had it
all to do over hank is that really the
name yeah well the girl's name was
Mallory who asked the question oh so you
named the planet milori yeah that's very
beautiful thank you thank you guys
figure I figured it's what your
grandfather would want I agree I agree
uh-huh I just thought of a joke that's
too dark for the podcast which is really
saying something okay we have another
question this one's from Kelsey who
writes Dear John and Hank I recently
moved to a new city and I'm in the
process of making friends however the
people I'm eating make significantly
more money than me and like to hang out
at bars and restaurants I can't afford
to go out multiple times a week how do I
continue to explore these burgeoning
relationships without draining my bank
account PS feel free to mention death in
your response thanks Kelsey I appreciate
that I will mention death in my response
here's the first thing that I would say
Kelsey if you can just find a way to get
to August you'll probably live to
January so worried about your weekly
spending when the first priority needs
to be getting out of February Yolo
[Laughter]
so here's what I would say this is
always difficult and it's complicated
and I think it's one of the reasons that
we now live in a culture in the United
States where people overwhelming
they spend most of their leisure time
with people who were in similar
socio-economic brackets mm-hmm and which
is a which is I think one of the biggest
social problems that we face as a
country but what I would say is don't go
out multiple times a week go out once a
week and then encourage your friends to
come with you once a week to do
something that is cheap like go to a
park and you know play feed pigeons for
some reason the idea that came into my
head Hank was to play a game where you
throw eggs back and forth to each other
but you try not to have the eggs break
but oh so there are they in fourth grade
not me not only is Kelsey seemingly not
in fourth grade what with going to bars
and and and etc but also that isn't that
inexpensive of a game because of course
the eggs cost money eggs are pretty
cheap sad chicken oh if you're watching
if you're watching your weekly budget
you don't want to just go throwing raw
eggs at people no I agree though though
compared with the cost of a cocktail in
New York City you could probably get
about four dozen eggs for that did I
ever tell you about the first time I
went to New York City with my best
friend Todd when we were in high school
my best friend Todd now did you have
insufficient funds
no that was Canada my best friend Todd
is from a very small town in Alabama and
grew up in a trailer park and had never
been New York City before and we went to
the Metropolitan Museum of Art and we
were at the restaurant there with with
my parents and Todd saw that two eggs
were nine dollars it was two eggs
scrambled for nine dollars and Todd said
to the waiter in his thick southern
accent for nine dollars
I want a suitcase full of eggs that I
can take home with me well now Todd is
an extremely successful dermatologist
but I suspect that dear he still won't
pay nine dollars for two eggs no I
understand that but I back to Kelsey's
question I believe I didn't say that
wrong did I is Kelsey it is killed
yeah I I think it's I think in
particularly in big cities this is a
huge issue because big cities are
optimized to to to provide for every
like little slice every little
demographic slice and where I live
there's just nothing you can spend much
money on so everybody is sort of on the
same page for the most part and but but
in New York City I think you really like
there are so many different you know
economic brackets and the city is
optimized to to to you know function for
each of them individually I cannot
imagine having to try to figure this out
but there are hopefully you one can when
doing these things managed to do it not
so conspicuously on a budget oh I'm just
having Seltzer now I'm taking a
medication that means that I can't I
can't drink anything that costs more
than $20 a glass that sort of thing and
don't don't be afraid to lie about that
about the little white guys John and I
are big fans of those and then a good
lie and then you know also be like you
know what I think is super fun is
Settlers of Catan and bring them back to
your place where I'm sure there's loads
of space for a large game playing table
because it is New York City and everyone
knows oh man when we lived in New York
Hank we entertained in our apartment in
the two and a half years that you live
there we entertained in our apartment
once yeah had friends over to our
apartment one time it sounds horrible
because it was so small it was so
cramped we were trying to like make
breakfast and our our kitchen didn't
have any drawers which is you know
inconvenient when you're cooking for two
but when you're cooking for six it's
just oh it's just such a pain let's move
on to another question so that I can
forget about my New York City kitchen
this question is from D Kista who asks
dear Hank and John I'm a need of some
dubious advice from two people who seem
to be in stable happy relationships I'm
a 21 year old woman in college attracted
the male type but it seems that nothing
that's your first mistake it seems that
nothing is working out from your
relationship wives I went out with this
guy once and I thought it was going
really well and he said he was looking
forward to another date and then
suddenly just cancelled and I haven't
heard from him who's since then my more
hip friends HIPPA some quotation marks
here have told me that this is called
ghosting where you just stopped talking
to someone to show disinterest but this
note makes no sense to me ah Oh God and
caps house all in caps why do people
take this seemingly easy way out when it
seems like it's just better for everyone
to tell the person you're not interested
we're adults for goodness sake oh god I
never want to be single again I can't
even give an encouraging answer to this
question because inside I'm just
cringing at all of my memories of dating
it's just so uncomfortable when you
don't know if you're going to spend the
rest of your lives together the whole
process is uncomfortable
yeah when you've been in a committed
relationship for like two years it's
still a little weird because you're like
is this forever or are you just like
yeah gonna be here for a while and then
you're gonna go do something else you've
always got that option you've always got
that thing that maybe sitting there that
that the choice it's always a choice
every day it's like do I want to be with
this person or not until you till you go
and you say you stand in a fancy
building and you say hey God God I want
you to hear this we're not gonna break
up and then God's like I heard you and
then then that takes a little bit of
that of that constant choice out of the
matter although I have to say hang and I
did not stand in a building or in fact
say any we didn't talk to God either
no yeah we you guys stood in a field and
promised to stay married we said it to
our God which was our friends and family
that's fair anyway point being Hank and
I are terrible terrible at giving dating
advice it's true but I have I have I
have watched this I've watched I have a
lot of young friends who are in in the
2016 dating scene which is admittedly
very different from my dating scene
which was just just grab on to and hold
the first one
who will listen to them it be Giants
with me and never let go the century
story of how Hank got married so III as
I watched this happen both on the
ghoster side and the ghost east side i
think what's what's kind of happening is
that it's it's kind of a side effect of
the the the tiny commitment of the text
message which is which is that it is a
really insignificant social act to text
someone and it is also kind and so
everyone recognizes that everyone
recognizes that this isn't a big deal
you texted me
no big but like because there is this
really low commitment form of
communication any other form of
communication seems really intense like
if you were to send an email to this
person it would be really strange and
like why are we establishing a business
relationship here and if you were to
call them people would be like oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa back down there
tiger
what are we married calling me on the
phone and and and but additionally to
this like very low impact like this is
the only way you can communicate and
basically I see that you are not like
it's not a big deal if I don't text back
because you are just texting me and it's
a low impact form of communication I
think also every single text message is
like like when you get one you have to
make the choice whether to text back or
not and if that choice isn't obvious
then there's always that like well I can
put this choice off and not texting is a
non choice
it is a wait till later to make this
decision choice while texting is an
active kind of a commitment an active
choice that you are making and choices
are kind of exhausting especially when
you have to make lots of them and so you
are increasing the number of these
choices that you have to make and I I've
watched and and it's like what I would
rather do is just not make a choice
right now so I'm gonna push push this
off until finally the choice gets made
for you because they're like oh well I
didn't text them back for two weeks it'd
be real weird to text back now but you
never really made that choice so I think
that there's a lot of like this isn't
about not being interested necessarily
of course sometimes it is
absolutely about not being interested
but oftentimes it's not just like I'm
not interested it's like I'm choice
exhausted I have to like and I don't
know like there's a lot going on and I
don't want to necessarily add this
because it's not like it's not the
hundred percent slam-dunk thing that I
imagined might could happen someday
having heard you Hank old man your way
through this question I have come to a
revelation that is even more terrifying
than the revelation I came to when I
realized that I myself was middle aged
which is that I I now have a younger
brother who is also middle-aged like
while you were answering that question
um early age and you entered middle age
it happened it happened I was I should
have used the word millennial at some
point I heard it happen and I'm upset we
need to move on no I should I should I
should just I should just go full on and
become a baby boomer and be like you
young kids need to make decisions it'd
be more careful with each other's
opinions of each other and I don't know
why all middle-aged people are from New
York oh my god Sarah and I had the best
time a couple weeks ago a friend of ours
who will remain nameless was using a
tinder like dating app and allowed us to
choose whether to swipe left or right on
their behalf and I mean I totally get it
it was so fun but let let's move on to
one last question before we get to the
Union do you not do you not think I had
good advice do you think that it was all
bad and that no I mean I think my advice
would be to listen to your hip friends
rather than Hank green I just watch I I
it's so hard to watch young people date
and it just seems it seems very
difficult and very yeah I mean I think
it was always hard from I think it was
always hard I think it was always
complicated but it does to our eyes
certainly seem more difficult and
complicated than it used to okay Hank
one last question before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon this
question is from Bethany who writes Dear
John and Hank last year my fiance and I
traveled to London
from Canada for vacation and of course
we attended an AFC Wimbledon game to
show our support
that's awesome Thank You Bethany
everybody in South London everybody who
visits London should really go to an AFC
Wimbledon game I myself am going to one
in a week
but more on that in a moment um the game
was incredibly fun to watch but the best
part of the experience for me was
joining in with the crowd as they sang
various songs to support the dons and
taunt the other team I've never been to
a sporting event where there was so much
singing and camaraderie like there was
at the Wimbledon game and I'm just
wondering how did this tradition of
singing at football games come about
I've never seen anything like it at
sporting events here in Canada it's true
you don't hear a lot of curling songs um
uh or even hockey songs you know hockey
hockey's mostly about like cheering or
making a lot of noise to make a lot of
noise rather than about singing specific
songs and that's mostly true in American
sports as well you know I think as far
as I know the tradition goes back you
know a hundred years that some of the
some of the songs that are sung are many
generations old but I don't know we're
singing at soccer games started it is
however a what a huge part of what is so
enjoyable about going to a Wimbledon
game or really any game with with good
with good support is that there's this
energy in the crowd that is almost like
the game is almost irrelevant to the
energy like one of my favorite moments
you can look this up on YouTube Hank I
think it was uh Aston Villa fans they
were there were like 1200 Aston Villa
fans uh playing away to Manchester City
and they were losing like seven nothing
and they started they started first off
they say saying one of my all-time
favorite football songs which is you're
nothing special we lose every week
[Laughter]
but then they then they started singing
let's pretend let's pretend let's
pretend we scored a goal and then they
sang that like three rounds of it and
then the all 1,200 of them just went
nuts like - screaming jumping up and
down hugging it was amazing and like you
know they weren't even like watching the
atrocity it was happening on the actual
football field and for me that is what
makes sports special and interesting and
especially makes soccer so interesting
is that it has that passion that extends
way beyond whatever the results of the
game are and I really would encourage
everybody to go to AFC Wimbledon games I
would also say it's only $35 a year to
become an owner of AFC Wimbledon if you
can you can go become an owner of the
team just like I am at the dons trust
and that's really cool too you get lots
of perks but yeah it is it is a really
special experience and one that I will
get to enjoy next week Hank because I am
going to an AFC Wimbledon game yeah next
week against Oxford United I think well
I am so excited for you as Oxford United
good at football let me look up and make
sure it's Oxford United first before I
answer your question it is Oxford United
now let me answer your question as to
whether they're any good I think every
game is incredibly important but Oxford
United is not just good they are very
good they are currently third which
means that they are in one of the
automatic promotion spots the top three
spots Wow in the league I'll get
promoted up to the third tier of English
football a AFC Wimbledon currently in
10th right but they have their only
three points out of six so it's it's so
we're just gonna jump right into the
news from AFC Wimbledon AFC Wimbledon
Hank played Luton Town last week now of
course you remember Luton Town because
of their significant role in AFC
Wimbledon's history I assume sure yes of
course you don't do you know Hank in
2011
just nine years after the club formed or
reformed AFC Wimbledon was in the fifth
tier right of English football yes they
were an amateur team not yet in the
Football League you couldn't play them
in FIFA and they made it to the play-off
final the game at the end of 90 minutes
the score was nil nil at the end of
extra time the score was nil nil and
then there was a penalty shootout and
nineteen-year-old goalkeeper Seb brown
saved two penalties against Luton Town
to send AFC Wimbledon up to the Football
League and back to their rightful spot
in professional English football that
same Luton Town a couple years later got
promoted so now we get to play them
twice every season and AFC Wimbledon
played Luton Town last week and one for
one Hank they won they won by three
goals which is great for goal difference
and two of the goals were scored by our
montserrat II and international the
Montserrat II and Messi some call him to
know who Leo Messi is yes yes I have
heard that name this is a tennis player
you're kidding right
yes okay thank God I am yeah so I call
him the monster adding and Messi the
monster ID and Messi scored two goals
AFC Wimbledon beats Luton Town for one
we're in 10th place I have to say I am
starting to properly dream so how where
are you at in the thing did you say oh
by the way that this the Maserati and
Messi is is Lyles Taylor or did you just
not say that name ever because I feel
like you should at least use his name
and not just call him I don't at this
point I don't think it's necessary to
say his name I think we all know I think
we all know I did so that's a booth
wants already and that's amazing there's
there can only be honest in the night
and it's loyal to you yeah so FC
Wimbledon to repeat myself Hank art okay
or did I part sorry okay but because
because different teams have played
different numbers of games
if AFC Wimbledon win all of their games
there's like 16 games left so obviously
that's not going
happen but like if AFC Wimbledon won all
of their games and if all the teams
above them won all of their games AFC
Wimbledon actually would make it into
the playoffs so great that's I'm getting
a little choked up here as you can tell
but yeah I'm starting I'm starting to
dream
I am truly I am dreaming with you John
I'm gonna have I'm gonna have a dream I
had a dream Austin I thought I had a
bunch of tattoos and a really nice body
I mean I might get an AFC Wimbledon
tattoo if they get promoted this season
I'm sure my wife would be delighted I'm
sure I'm sure all right you wanna hear
some what's the news from ours this week
all right well as you as you may have
heard you know we got it we got to make
when we get to Mars we got to feed
ourselves and one way to do it is just
to bring all the food with us but as we
learned from the Martian if you bring
all that food and then suddenly you need
to spend another six months on Mars you
got to take your Thanksgiving dinner cut
up those potatoes plant them the Martian
soil and become you know become the
greatest botanist on the planet and it
works fantastically in the book in the
movie so NASA is actually looking to
simulate growing Mars potatoes in Peru
the home of the potato by the way if you
were if you did not if you did not know
where potatoes came from South America
surprisingly somewhat surprisingly just
because it is such a big part of what we
consider European cuisine but not not
since only only after the Columbian
Exchange as they say here on tier Hank
and John the the the partnership is
between NASA and I'm not kidding you
Leamas International potato center which
is a thing that exists there there are
many many many many different varieties
of potato we do not see the vast
majority of them here in the US grocery
stores but there are 4,500 varieties
that are registered at Leamas
International potato center and hundreds
of them will including some genetically
modified ones will be used to we sent
through a series of tests to see how
good they would be at producing potatoes
just not just potatoes for one
generation but potatoes for many
generations of potatoes on the surface
of Mars and as we've got to deal with
you know the amounts of of you know the
the soil would need to be cleaned up
before it is you know if we're on Mars
the Martian soil we need to cleaned up
to some extent before this is done but
you know you got a test for for salt the
amount of light that they need you know
the amount of water that they need is
best if they use less water and produce
more potato and there's like radiation
concerns so but there they are confident
that at least some of these potatoes
will pass passed through these tests and
we will have we'll have the right stuff
for going to potato two potato land with
and by potato land I mean Mars and
that's what we're gonna call it well but
someday we'll be known as potato and all
of our potatoes will be grown on Mars
we'll just uh nothing but Martian food
earth will be for humans Mars for
potatoes there's only one food John it
should obviously be potato I mean if
you're only gonna have one food potatoes
is not a bad option okay so before we go
we need to answer a few things from
previous episodes that have been brought
to our attention via our email address
Hank and John at gmail.com first off
Hank Mel wrote in about cereal in your
latest podcast John confessed he puts
water on his cereal this intrigued me
because I hate milk I thought I thought
putting water on cereal was generally
unacceptable and that nobody would
actually try it but hearing that at
least one person in the world has not
only tried it but does it regularly I
thought I had no reason not to try it
myself so this morning I had water on my
cereal and as advertised
watered cereal provides the same
softness that milk does without having
to add actual milk this has saved my
breakfast no longer will I suffer the
gross nosov milk or cut the roof of my
mouth on dry cereal I don't care if I
get judgmental looks in the morning I
can finally enjoy cereal in a way I
never could have before thank you for
revolutionising my mornings sincerely
Mel you are welcome meld well it's hard
it's hard for me to argue with that John
it's hard for me to say that you are the
monster that you are after mal has had
this wonderful life-changing experience
but we've
so gotten about 400 emails from people
who are disgusted daddy and an awful lot
of comments cuz he made a whole video
about this we've also got a message from
Till who says that not only are there
feral cows in British Columbia and
Hawaii but also in Hong Kong and yes
Hong Kong there are feral cows in Hong
Kong I'm not even kidding you Jeff
made some corn dog cake for his kids and
it wasn't bad and he attached a picture
of his kids and they do indeed look very
happy
Amanda writes in to say that she works
at a food bank in element Alameda County
and thus knows all about how long food
lasts after its sell-by date and indeed
macaroni and cheese is perfectly fine in
fact dried pasta is usually good two
years after the sell-by date and she
includes a PDF from the Alameda County
Food Bank that is a guide for how long
you can eat things after their sell-by
dates remark aware gonna go ahead and
post that as well as some pictures of
feral cows in Hong Kong to our patreon
page which you can access even if you
aren't don't donate but feel free to
donate and yeah we are so you can see
both of that I thought it was I have to
say having read Amanda's email I was
dead wrong about food on how long it's
good for and as she says John you have
fallen prey to what the food
manufacturers want you to think about as
food safety but is really about wanting
their products to be at peak flavor so
that's really important and an
interesting point and one that I will
bear in mind for the rest of my life so
we all learned something today Hank but
what else did we learn
ah we learned that sometimes when your
team doesn't score any goals and is
being absolutely ripped to little tiny
pieces by the other team it doesn't
matter and you can still have a good
time because really it's about
camaraderie and and singing songs and
being together and believing in the same
things and we were in that strawberry
flavor is a not strawberry flavor but it
is delicious
ethyl methyl phenyl guys at 8:00
we learned we learned that John has a
strategy called a empathic listening
which is has something to do with Deanna
Troi from Star Trek we also learned that
heck doesn't really listen to me when
I'm talking on dear Hank and Shelly we
learned that grief is complicated and
that you shouldn't judge yourself for it
but that you should just go on yeah you
shouldn't judge yourself if you need to
get yourself a donut let's go get a
donut
yeah just enjoy an evening donut
speaking of which Hank two different
employees here at the Indianapolis
offices of dear Hank and John brought in
Friday doughnuts oh we have three dozen
donuts for just nine people it is a it's
an absolute donut bonanza here today and
I'm so grateful to everyone I look
forward to seeing if I can eat ten
donuts by myself all right donut
disaster donut has after 2016 it
happened I was good oh I should also
mention that dear Hank and John now has
an intern thanks to our lovely support
at patreon we've been able to bring on
at paid intern name is Claudia and
Claudia will be helping out with dear
Hank and John in various ways so if you
ever interact with with Claudia I don't
know what why you would but she'll be
helping out mostly she'll be helping out
us she we will still be doing all the
public facing things actually in fact
this voice that you're hearing now is
actually Claudia's impression of me I'm
not doing this at all that's what the
intern does she just yeah I know it was
called both of us introducing herself
yeah in fact the whole podcast has been
hosted by Claudia she's doing both of
our voices she's doing a great job I'm
really the best part about her doing
this podcast is that she's so
successfully made it not funny yeah it's
it's a really a remarkable spot-on
impression of two guys really just
struggling with with with being
interesting
and in their own mortality and and not
really caring at all whether or not the
things that they say on this comedy
podcast could ever be considered in any
planet you know
meloria Mars or Earth
meloria is my new favorite planet okay
Hank we really have to go today's
podcast was edited by Nicholas Jenkins
and possibly Claudia I don't know our
theme music is by gunnarolla my voice is
giving out and as we say in our hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]